hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday my 19th 2018 what's going on how
why yeah is that loud enough my ears
shot what's going on I'm really I'm
super late I apologize I apologize to
anybody I may offended Rolex Americans
anybody indigenous to the clock world
you know
I'm sorry original I learned that when I
was up in Canada they do not want to be
called indigenous they want to be called
the original co G's the O G's of this
[ __ ] that's what they want to be called
pre provinces you white [ __ ] I
believe that's what they said except
they said it with a drum no they didn't
do they the originals up in Canada they
communicate through drums too you know
so funny once white people got their
hands on all of a sudden all
communication just started with that
instrument well that's because we
invented the [ __ ] phone you dumb [ __ ]
hey keep it [ __ ] classy there sorry
I'm in a fucked-up mood I flew back from
Toronto late last night I was in
Kitchener or Kitchener I have no idea
came up with a great [ __ ] touristy
t-shirt for those people out there all
right if you can't stand the heat get
out of the Kitchener huh
they need something they need some
swagger out there cuz everybody was
giving me [ __ ] life look like playing a
live there we go first of all I was just
in Toronto and then secondly those
people like entertainment too but now
they got to drive an hour and a half all
the way in they got to pay for Park and
if they're gonna booze now they got to
get a room and all of a sudden becomes
this big [ __ ] deal
so I like going to places like Kitchener
and Hamilton that Casino on the other
side of Detroit and then there was that
other one that Casino Rama that gig
where I left the rental car ever tell
you guys that [ __ ] story
I left a rental car there man
we went out we did the show I'm not
naming any names in this one okay me and
some friends of mine okay not my usual
friends these friends were readers these
were big readers and they never
predicted anything okay they didn't
predict someone was gonna be a
hall-of-famer after one at-bat it was
not anybody like that
wink-wink nudge-nudge anyways so we were
up there Casino Rama and we drove up
from someplace else I can't remember
we've done a couple gigs out there and
like March Madness was going on or some
sort of ladies hockey for some medal or
some [ __ ] I can't remember what and we
went up did the show and we went out and
got [ __ ] hammered hammered knowing
that we had an early flight and then I
had to return this rental car so we keep
looking to watch guys you know we kind
of got to be up at 5:00 a.m. it's it's
midnight that's five hours sleep one
more one more blah blah blah next yeah
we got it we got it I swear to God like
3:00 in the friggin morning and I am
hammered
did I mention that was drunk if I was
[ __ ] hammered so wake up like two
hours later you know with a bunch of
snacks open from the [ __ ] hotel bar
one of those nights you know tried to
get down like another whiskey I've maybe
got one swig out of it like Denzel in
that movie where he [ __ ] flies the
plane upside down he somehow overcomes
losing his rear stabilizer the first guy
ever in the history of aviation and then
I you know open can of Pringles in a
KitKat I think so I stumbled downstairs
right where you know and we get in the
[ __ ] car right I'm still [ __ ]
hammered I'm like guys I'm too [ __ ]
drunk to drive and I'm like dude the
airport's right down the street this is
how every fate fatal drinking and
driving story happens it's right down
the street so we look at our [ __ ] GPS
because we're still we still on the
hotel's [ __ ] thing there and we were
trying to memorize it because none of us
got a plan when we were up there well
wouldn't you know we leave the hotels
[ __ ] airspace and we can't figure out
where we're going it's it's [ __ ]
low visibility it's still pitch-black
out and now we have no map I don't know
where I'm at and we're all [ __ ]
hammered and I was just like dude I
can't do this so we literally got like a
[ __ ] quarter mile down the street
turn back around go back to the hotel we
say listen to because we kind of you
know hit it off with the guy behind the
[ __ ] the counter that can do it's a
favor you know what can you is there any
way you can return this rental car the
guy goes no problem no problem
we'll call you a cab I got my buddy
he'll come down he'll return the [ __ ]
thang blah blah blah no problem so now
we're sweating it right but turns out
the pilots and [ __ ] are also waiting for
a car and we were on their flight or
whatever somehow so antrum it's all
[ __ ] foggy so we end up getting there
we make the flight back laughing our
asses off hey we did it you know what a
good [ __ ] that guy returns the [ __ ]
car what an awesome guy right and I pass
out on the plane and I wake up in LA
like nothing ever happened
so I [ __ ] maybe look up three weeks
later I get this phone call from the
rental company and they were like yeah
mr. burr you ever gonna return that
rental car I told this story wrong I
shouldn't told you that I left it to the
hotel guy I had completely forgot I mean
that's how drunk I was I don't even
remember that part where I said that I
was gonna [ __ ] that I told the guy at
the hotel and I was like yeah return it
returned like three weeks ago and at
this point I've done like three more
road gigs so I don't even remember it
I'm like yeah yeah it did
how did you get my number you keep my
number I was all about me so they start
badgering me in my [ __ ] world and I'm
just like you know after like the fourth
a fifth phone call I was like listen
stop calling me I returned the rental
car stopped calling me on my cell phone
I'm at work and blah blah blah and then
just one time I don't know what happened
like the sixth time they called me
something just clicked I was like wait a
minute was that that gig where I was
hammered and there were clouds on the
ground and I the guy behind the counter
said he was gonna or some people called
fog we're gonna [ __ ] return the
rental car oh [ __ ] so I had to call
after yelling at these people had to
comment be like yeah listen I'm the guy
you called like six times ago
I got really drunk and I tried to drive
but I couldn't the guy at the hotel said
he was gonna bring Pam thinking that
they ended up [ __ ] going down that
the car was still sitting there I hate
to pay a month's rental on that thing I
can't even [ __ ] tell you how much
money that cost me but whatever that's
not the big news the big news as
announced by barstool sports remember I
was telling you rough and rowdy was
gonna be a juggernaut and just blah blah
blah that and I thought it was just the
greatest friggin idea ever it's
literally it's like American Idol meets
the UFC all those people that think they
can [ __ ] sing and want to prove it
and then look what happens some of them
come out of there and they win Grammys
so who knows maybe one of these people
when there's rough and rowdy thing could
actually someday get in the UFC house
right and then then next thing you know
[ __ ] he's on one of those paper views
but until then they're at the barstool
sports rough and rowdy number tree quoi
and I'm actually gonna be ringside
throwing in some jokes you guys got to
get this man you have to get this
[ __ ] pay-per-view I'm telling you I'm
gonna be making fun of people I'm gonna
be making fun of myself it's it's $15.99
to watch regular people beat the [ __ ]
out of each other you know what I mean
it's the greatest thing greatest thing
of all time this is like there's certain
things you just see coming you're like
this is gonna be [ __ ] huge I the
second I saw this it's like I'm gonna
watch every [ __ ] one of these things
and I don't know I was just talking
positively about it and then barstool
reached out to you with an email and
they're like you want to do this so it's
just like yeah yeah absolutely so I'm
gonna be there so tune in let me see if
I can get you the date here I'm so
[ __ ] excited about this I can't even
tell you when the hell is it gonna be
I'm the worst
does anybody promote [ __ ] worse than me
I know that it's going to be in [ __ ]
at North Carolina April 13th it's gonna
be April 13th Charlotte North Carolina
former hometown of the Nature Boy Ric
Flair I mean everything's just this is
serendipity it's all [ __ ] lining up I
can't wait so please you and your
friends order the goddamn fight get
yourself some beers and who knows maybe
you watch your get inspired and the next
time you'll be honest that's just that
easy yo do you ever wanna be on TV try
to knock somebody out
finally there's a vehicle for you so
anyways why are you so late today bill
well I had a busy day I why I flew back
from Toronto after two awesome shows in
Kitchener yeah they're definitely there
aren't there on the toilets now I've
been such awesome people there and a
great venue and so I flew back late at
night because I wanted to be you know
get home late at night so when my
daughter woke up the next day I was
gonna be there you don't I mean because
of what I do you know so I missed some
days sometimes you know so like
literally the UPS guy comes walking up
to walk and she's pointing going dah dah
dah dah like I can't handle it I have
too much [ __ ] guilt over it all right
however I do have to provide for my
family so anyways I hung with my
daughter in the morning and then I had
this meeting from 10:00 to 12:00 and
then when I came back my wife told me
that she was gonna take our daughter to
go see the Easter Bunny and I was like
well I don't want to miss that so I went
over there and you know last year she
was fine because she was only like you
know four or five months old and this
year she's like you know coming up on a
year and a half or whatever and you know
I just felt this vibe I was just she was
looking at the [ __ ] person in this
outfit and I'm just looking at it like I
don't know about this one right so we're
trying to be like hey and the bunny's
[ __ ] waving at her and [ __ ] and I
went up and I'm shaking the rabbit's
hand and stuff like see it's safe it's
not cutting my head off and she's just
looking at the rabbit like I don't know
about this man she's like that dude in
platoon like
feel about this man so we bring her up
there and immediately like I go to kind
of hand it to the to the [ __ ] do it
in the bunny suit and I just feel her
just grab two handfuls of my t-shirt
like oh no and then I was she started
screaming and then I handed it to my
wife my wife ended up having to sit down
with her with the rabbit
she's totally crying totally freaked out
and all that and the whole time I'm just
sitting there going why do we do this to
kids why am I doing this and a frickin
this kid out with a [ __ ] person and a
goddamn bunny suit it makes no sense to
the kid and at the end at the end of all
of this horseshit it's a [ __ ] lie the
whole thing is a [ __ ] lie and then
one day you got to turn around and tell
you kid it's not real and it's just a
selfish adult thing because you love
your kids so much you wanted to see them
get excited you know and you grew up and
you saw how mean and cold-hearted the
world is you just want to see them
[ __ ] believe in something and then
just early on you just break their trust
by telling them that there's these
[ __ ] people that come by some of them
are animals and I mean some of them are
fairies and all of this [ __ ] but then
what do you dope do you tell your kid
that they that they don't exist and then
they go to school to come to school like
some grizzled [ __ ] vet and let me
tell you something kids it's all
[ __ ] right just tell all these kids
the bunny doesn't exist and Santa Claus
doesn't exist to that everybody's
getting [ __ ] mad at your kid it's a
great life lesson actually for your kid
that's what happens when you tell the
truth he's on his [ __ ] stump right
now yeah if you ever want to get yelled
at there you go send your kid to school
with the truth about Santa Claus and the
Easter Bunny and you just say your kid
just say listen you know everybody talks
about reading to your kid trying to give
them a head start and all that why don't
you [ __ ] get my head start and not
[ __ ] tell him about all that [ __ ] one
of my relatives did that with one of my
nephews
you know and the kid grew up fine they
just sat it down like yeah listen it's
all [ __ ] you know I remember when I
found out my older brother told me and
he felt betrayed and when he told me I
felt like an adult I was like no way is
that what that ain't oh thanks for the
heads up then I sat there and kept my
mouth shut like an old-school mobster I
never told my other brothers never said
[ __ ] I just sat down
oh yeah he's coming right down that
[ __ ] chimney then I sit there
laughing listening my younger brothers
telling me stories iswe go right off the
roof I'll dead you lying piece of [ __ ]
you know let me know let me know who
they really were I learned who I could
trust in my family having that inside
information I think that's why they're
trying to get that Alexa in everybody's
house so then they can tell you know who
they can trust and who they can't trust
and not really for a good reason either
you know there is corrupt as I am except
they're running [ __ ] I have no idea what
I'm talking about right now
um I lied to you guys earlier I didn't
have a meeting from 10:00 to 12:00 what
I did was I went out and I flew out to
Camarillo and then down the coast along
Malibu on one of the most perfect
[ __ ] days ever
while the whales are migrating okay I
should have literally had like [ __ ]
yoga me yoga music playing in my [ __ ]
headset it was it was [ __ ]
unbelievable it's unbelievable so uh I
don't know whatever
sorry I've got you got me I apologize
and we were supposed to take our kid
would be totally honest with you guys
and I'm supposed to take the kid to see
the Easter Bunny tomorrow and then my
wife scheduled flip flopped around and
it was more convenient for her to go
today it was more convenient for us to
go tomorrow but it's more convenient for
her to go today so what do you think
happened you know what happened god damn
it you know exactly what happened oh I
went to a Toronto Raptors game by the
way on the Sunday and I went to that OKC
game the game was like [ __ ] 132 to
something crazy like that was almost
like an all-star game score and we had
great seats and all of that stuff it
just was [ __ ] awesome great fan base -
Jesus Christ I knew you guys loved the
Leafs but obviously Toronto's doing
great this year but uh it's a really fun
game to watch and that knocked off now
I've seen every professional Canadian
[ __ ] team a home game of them except
for the goddamn [ __ ] Ottawa Senators
and every time I schedule something to
go see one of their games something
comes up and I can't make it alright the
first time unfortunately one of my great
friends in life passed away and I had to
go to the funeral and all that so that's
understandable
all right and the second time it was
just like alright I'm flying in two days
early I'm a dad now I'm gonna miss 48
hours with my daughter to go to a [ __ ]
Ottawa Senators game I couldn't justify
it
so I cancelled then so it's really has
nothing to do with Ottawa or their
franchise they're running that type of
[ __ ] but um I believe that they're
actually making a new arena isn't that
unbelievable take what is wrong with the
other one the other one is totally fine
that's like the Atlanta Braves moving
out of there totally perfectly fine
baseball stadium the Atlanta Falcons
moving out of there totally perfectly
fine [ __ ] dome like what are we doing
and then they take wait what do they do
with all of that mid today I won't stay
not as someone should make a [ __ ]
documentary on that when they knock down
a [ __ ] stadium that works fine
alright but the owners all agree [ __ ]
move them you're fat [ __ ] I'm sick of
seeing cities being held hostage by
these [ __ ] crybaby owners especially
the [ __ ] NFL those [ __ ] [ __ ]
such a great game such a crew a console
that runs it how much more [ __ ] money
to those [ __ ] need to me need to
make before they'll pony up for a
[ __ ] Stadium
you know without threatening everybody
that they're gonna walk out no one full
well that most people are like me and
they don't read they don't have any
other
no one full well that if they that the
politicians would be like well if we let
this [ __ ] thing go I'm not gonna get
voted into office I'm gonna Bob Kraft
even though he pony up money for the
stadium he was gonna go to Connecticut
him and his dumb [ __ ] loafers I love
the guy by there's two things that
happen in the pause a bunch of things
that happen my history as a patriot fan
that bugged me Bill Parcells telling the
team that he was allegedly that he was
gonna he wasn't coming back the next
year before we played the Green Bay
Packers
that's why I've still yet to watch the
two bills okay because somebody who was
not connected to the football team told
me a long time ago that he did that and
I believed it back then the way I
believed that there was a Santa Claus
Bill Parcells has the same body type is
Santa Claus and the whole thing comes
together and I've just never been able
to [ __ ] forgive the guy for something
that I'm not even sure if he even did
okay what else what Bob Kraft said he
was gonna move him to Connecticut that
was [ __ ] annoying we should have let
him do it
great movement Connecticut moving to the
[ __ ] Hartford Whalers old building
see if you can make it work down there
you can't make anything work and [ __ ]
Connecticut they're too divided you know
some a giant fan some of Patriot fans
some are dirt poor the others are in the
Illuminati and there's some Klan members
I mean think about that what what
[ __ ] product can you sell that's
gonna appeal to all of those people
there's a reason why Connecticut lost
the whaler state they deserved it no I'm
just kidding I was actually talking to
somebody when I was up in Canada that
like what was great about the [ __ ]
hockey divisions when I was a kid when I
was just a lad the Adams division and
the Patrick's division if you had a
[ __ ] car you could literally drive to
every road game your team had within its
division you could probably get there
within you know a couple of hours except
for the Quebec Nordiques they were way
the [ __ ] up there you jumped on a plane
they were all just like fly to Montreal
fly to
hello drive down to Hartford many other
notables Nordiques the Canadians the
Sabres the Whalers and the Bruins then I
feel like I'm missing somebody I was so
long ago and then the Patrick Division
the Islanders the Rangers the Devils the
Flyers in the capitals all five of them
were right there and then the road trip
the long one was Pittsburgh all of them
right [ __ ] there
it's like when you used to see like
those those things they doin like you
know back in the day when baseball was
all unlike the East Coast essentially
and they would just take trains and
there was two teams in Boston three
teams in New York two teams in Philly
the Philadelphia Athletics the
Philadelphia Phillies the New York
Giants knew the Brooklyn Dodgers the New
York Yankees formerly the New York
Highlanders formally the original
Baltimore Orioles then the new Paul
tomorr Orioles formerly the st. Louis
Browns is it amazing I know all of this
[ __ ] and can't do [ __ ] simple math
and have no idea what's going on in the
world I tried to get a little smarter
though on the flight back i watch this
Kent Bernstadt this whole thing on
Vietnam and I watched one that was
basically 1970 to 1971 and what I loved
about the documentary is he does not
spare the horrors of all of those people
that are just showing the dead bodies
and all of that [ __ ] and just like and
just done so even-handedly people who
protested the war is one marine was
saying like I had no problem with people
protesting the war you know that's one
of the great things about this country
and all that type of stuff but like
those people that were like yelling at
him and punching his car and all that
[ __ ] like they took it too far and I
found that really interesting you know
that you can you can because we're kind
of I feel like we live in that right now
to the left except for some reason
they're not protesting this never-ending
[ __ ] war that is bankrupting this
country
because the people in power geniusly
have sold this one that if you criticize
it you don't support troops and you're a
socialist / I think you're in Isis I
think that's the way it goes if you're
even just as an American going like hey
man like I'm down with this country and
stuff but we're spending a billion
dollars a month to fight 3,500 people on
a jungle gym the Train on a jungle gym
like that's just for my business
standpoint how are we gonna continue to
sustain this if you just even ask that
that's immediately put into the you
don't support the troops you don't
appreciate people fighting for your
freedom you're a piece of [ __ ] let's
ruin your career and I feel that they
learned that in Vietnam when they kind
of learned that if they lost the pump
obviously you lose the public support
eventually you're gonna lose the [ __ ]
war in watching these people giving
these speeches so we don't end up at
another Vietnam and blah blah blah blah
and then just seeing some of these
hippies acting like me to people you
know totally just taking it too far that
if somebody even looks like their whole
life should just [ __ ] be destroyed
you know what I mean
one person tries to look up a skirt if
somebody's walking up with stairs you
know flight of stairs all of a sudden
they're doing jello shots with Harvey
Weinstein out in some godforsaken place
in [ __ ] Arizona I got a great reality
show you have Harvey Weinstein and OJ
Simpson if they do a road trip right and
they got it's like they got they start
in LA and they got 36 hours to get to
Atlanta to pick up Paula Deen it's like
the Gumball Rally you know and that she
cuz then she has to go into this Big
Brother house and decide whether or not
she wants to marry Dog the Bounty Hunter
I'm just I'm just throwing this out
there like this is just day and I want
to host it and have all these dumb
events like [ __ ] that guy in Survivor
that screams at everybody my wife always
watches survivor and I just can't that's
so [ __ ] I get so much anxiety you
know bloating
slowing down they need to hurry up it's
like shut the [ __ ] up we know we need to
do you explain the game you're [ __ ]
shredded [ __ ] he is in great shape for
the amount you know he's got to be sick
of it though
I feel like with that guy every I feel
like for me I feel every [ __ ] season
he gets a little more angry because at
some point I mean it's just a finely
oiled machine but like he sort of has
stopped growing as a person because now
he's stuck in Groundhog Day and it's
just like and they do it like they've
been on the air for like 18 years and
they're like in their 50th season like I
don't know how many times this poor
bastard has to fly to a [ __ ] island
in Fiji and yell at people about you
know how they need to bring a plate of
[ __ ] peace you know while walking on
some fire whatever the [ __ ] is that
that guy does can you imagine just just
sitting there trying to think of another
[ __ ] thing that they have to do I
don't know I have no idea it's like that
American Ninja was it American Ninja
Warrior which I love that show too but
it's just like every fight I think
somebody's got to sit there and think of
a something that requires even more grip
strength I swear to God by the time they
get in there fifty season you can have
to [ __ ] be doing pull-ups you know
only holding on with your feet the
people who trained for that thing you
know you're gonna have all generations
are gonna continue to train for that
thing I swear to God our big toes gonna
start sliding down the left side of your
foot in the right side of your foot
depending on which one you're looking at
you're gonna have thumbs again like a
[ __ ] ape by the way I saw one of the
best [ __ ] YouTube videos you know
I'll give you like those mashups you
know and a lot of times you just pick
two songs that are the same tempo right
you just [ __ ] take the music out of
one you take the lyrics Emelia you slam
it together I know you know maybe speed
it up a little bit but somebody did
rats round and round with Marvin Gaye I
heard it through the grapevine check on
the Twitter page we just posted it we
have it posted by the time this is up
and just the way it fits is incredible
like it actually sounds right and then I
was I don't know what the [ __ ] I was
just on YouTube looking at a bunch of
videos and I somehow found this band
where this guy does this impression of
Michael McDonald and he's singing Iron
Maiden's run to the hills but it's
totally sung like Michael McDonald and
but the music that they wrote sounds
like a Michael McDonald song like it
doesn't see cuz I was sitting they
listen going [ __ ] I mean I know this
song she's like what man came across the
sea he brought us pain and beautiful Bri
I won't torture anymore
killed took up I said he took up Gabe
for his small dude you gotta listen to
music underneath it it sounds like right
around the time when he was working with
Steely Dan doing all of that [ __ ] who
ever would have thought that some band
could sit there and write some blue-eyed
soul to [ __ ] iron mate alright with
that let me do a little we'll post that
one too
Oh probably already have it posted by
the time you listen to this ring alright
hang on a second I ain't gonna say
alright I could do the [ __ ] reads
here for the week I gotta go do the
[ __ ] reads here for the week o dollar
shave club dude dude you're tired of
[ __ ] shaving and pain a [ __ ]
zillion dollars would it be great if
there was a [ __ ] shave club that
could do it for just a dollar dollar
shave club if the first thing that pops
into your [ __ ] melon when you hear
the name Dollar Shave Club is an amazing
affordable shave then here is more
information you need to know Dollar
Shave Club delivers to you everything
you need to look smell and feel [ __ ]
awesome kid shampoo body wash
in toothpaste and of course the best
raises you'll ever use you'll get an
amazing high-quality shave I love when
they pad sentences with adjectives
you're gonna know why can't you just be
an amazing shave earning high quality
shape an amazing high quality
super-duper shave every morning using
Dollar Shave club's executive [ __ ]
andreza oh you know you make it even
better you use it with that doctor
copies easy shave butter
doctor copies is your chef bottle put it
on your balls and shave your pubes he
put some coffee shaped butter on his
[ __ ] balls you use it with it dr.
Carver's shea butter to help the razor
gently glide across your skin you have
to experience it Tony you're gonna fill
up a little kid another must have
experience is how Dollar Shave Club
delivers everything to you that means no
more trips to the store wandering the
aisles having Tourette's like me hunting
for raises shampoo and toothpaste kid
then having to play at being a cashier
scanning the [ __ ] bag in your own stuff
it's a nightmare join Dollar Shave Club
today and for just five dollars five
bucks you saw a bucket with three with
free shipping you'll get two six six
Jesus Christ six blade executive raizy
gonna [ __ ] kill somebody with that
plus trial sizes of shea butter body
cleanser and one wipe Charlies then keep
the blades coming for a few more bucks a
month get a dollar shave club get yours
at dollarshaveclub.com that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash / oh look
who's here stamps.com everybody the US
Postal Service is an important tool for
any business stamps.com is the easiest
way to access all the amazing services
of the post office I don't understand
why the post office hasn't made an offer
to buy stamps calm and then they just
sell
their locations turn them into [ __ ]
Buffalo Wild Wings or you rent them out
to a corporation that's what you do and
then you still own the property that's
what the [ __ ] I would do knock down a
little bit of the the deficit from
fighting these [ __ ] nitwits who don't
even have uniforms right you knock it
down a little bit look at making solvent
problems like Galaga
stamps.com never closes print postage
for letters and packages at your
convenience 24/7 print postage for any
mail class right from your own computer
the exact amount of postage every time
never unto pay or overpay again I can
mail any letter any package using just
my computer and printer and the mail
carrier picks it up mail everything from
postcards to envelope 2-pack of the
packages domestic or international
create your own stamps calm account in
minutes online with no equipment no
lease and no long-term commitments click
print mail and you're done by the way
I'm going to be making the sick ass
[ __ ] poster for all my big tour dates
this year it's gonna be a little nod to
me turn in half a century old I use yoga
for the average I use I use stamps.com
yeah whenever I send out my [ __ ]
posters I just said that right now you
two can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale all right oh my god
speaking of Vietnam speaking speaking of
Vietnam bike mechanic from Vietnam how
[ __ ] weird is that you know who would
have thought who would have thunk that I
would talk about Ken Burns Vietnam by
the way I have to watch her eat Ken
Burns I swear to god Ken Burns could do
a [ __ ] nine part documentary on
clipping you goddamn toenails and I
would watch that alright cuz he would
somehow it would be fascinating and
speaking of amazing television that I
watched when I was on the plane
make sure I get the name of the show
right I watched that new Mike judge
animated show what is it tour bus from
the tour bus have as anybody watched
that yet
he basically talks to all these [ __ ]
lunatic outlaw country singers okay and
they tell stories about being out on the
road I say I don't I I've yet to go I've
yet to see one where somebody didn't
pull a gun on somebody three out of four
that I watched the people involved
actually shot the other person one got
off one went to jail I'm telling you the
once I watched I watched the Jerry Lee
Lewis Johnny paycheck and then there was
this guy Billy Joe something or other
and there was one other one that I
watched they were unbelievable you know
if Mike judge is doing its gonna be
quality maybe percent bought head office
space of course what's the name of this
king of the hill Jesus Christ my brains
going I'm going to mush idiocracy which
a lot of people didn't see because it
went straight to [ __ ] you know this
is a little too accurate
anyways I I cannot say enough about that
show I have to watch every [ __ ] one
of those and you're really seeing like
basically an America that no longer
exists half the [ __ ] that they do it's
like dude there's no [ __ ] way you
could do that now
just with all the cellphone cameras and
all of that and and you just peer into
the way I don't know the way men an
extreme version of an American male
thought back in the day the way they
handled [ __ ] they've thought process it
just was just thought I can't even
unlike 20 different [ __ ] levels that
show is unbelievable you have to watch
it guys it on his true God one of the
ruin one thing this guy is on trial for
shooting this guy in the face okay and
the judge goes well couldn't you just
ran away I walked away saying he didn't
have to do it basically and the guy
looks at the judge he's like he's like
buddy I'm from Texas
we don't run says that it is own [ __ ]
trial anyways I don't know I'm
butchering it you got to see it the part
where [ __ ] Jerry Lee Lewis considers
driving over Liberace so that be quote
one less piano play and [ __ ]
that he had to compete compete with just
imagine that animated that's I I get
it's incredible show incredible show and
I resent every podcast listener for not
telling me that it existed you probably
did I just miss the emails alright okay
here we go bike mechanic from Vietnam
hey there mister Billy Oh rice ball
I found your podcast last year and have
been listening ever since I'm currently
a bike mechanic at a local shop here in
Hanoi Vietnamese born and raised well I
bet you get a ton of work everybody
rides bikes over there right and I'm
basing that on Hollywood movies that
I've seen alright actually Tom roads
always does gigs over there and tells me
how beautiful it is and Tom Rhodes is
going to be in Vietnam he was telling me
and the next couple of months I believe
at least this year I forget what the
date is
alright I recently met the loveliest
Colombian lady a beautiful beautiful
women in the world at the shop and I am
smitten I don't doubt it
problem is she's only gonna be here for
one month before continuing to the next
destination on a world tour and what
better time for you to get in there in
between Oh guys I'm sorry have a nice
romance she's covering for my fellow
co-worker who's on a trip of her own
traveling across the country I'm happy
enough to have a month to spend with her
I don't care if she's gonna be gone
forever afterwards I have no idea what
to do though always have been with women
I've got no game I'm always a bit needy
oh that's a bad one not knowing what to
say is easy that's easy you just you got
to start bombing like a comedian like
the way a person learns how to become a
comedian you just write some [ __ ] you
don't know if it's funny you go up there
you [ __ ] you know lose on nine out of
ten but you keep that one
and you build off of that and then
eventually you have an act all right
needy he can't be needy I'm a bit needy
and I'm constantly doubting myself all
right well I'm with you on the second
one and whether or not she likes me I
know it's a good thing to do and I
should stop thinking that way but it's
not easy for me I guess I need some
words of advice and encouragement thank
you very much and go hug yourself I
would you just you just got a the thing
about doubting yourself and being needy
and all of that and just being filled
with doubt and no confidence is that is
um that's one of those things where when
you're really young
the sooner you address that the better
your life is gonna be okay because that
you're so young at this point that it's
not I don't think it's it just doesn't
have it's um it's in you like if you try
to deal with it in your late 30s the way
I did so and then you find out all this
[ __ ] you were afraid of that you thought
was I gotta walk up this [ __ ]
mountain it was business it was like
stepping up under a curb so first of all
in a good way who gives a [ __ ] if you
ask this chick out she shoots you down
who gives a [ __ ]
you all you have is a funny [ __ ]
story and in an experience asking a
woman out especially if you think she's
out of out of your league that's even
better
you know anything you want to do you got
it you got a play with people that are
better than you if you want to get
better playing sports you know like I
remember this guy was telling me about
as far as like getting together if you
play an instrument jamming with people
like when we were kids always to be like
hey we should jam well how long you been
playing oh I've been playing for years
I've only been playing a year I can't
play you can be too good it's like no
you should go play with them because
they
they're gonna pull you up alright so
it's the same thing with this thing you
got this beautiful Colombian woman she's
gonna be leaving soon so first of all
the fact that there's gonna be no
relationship beyond this there's gonna
be no pressure so the level of fun that
you guys can have is gonna be ridiculous
so I would just start hitting on her
personally just make subtle comments
just tell us you whatever she's wearing
tell her she looks good she asked I
don't know should I wear this and I you
always do you look good everything
really yeah I think you're beautiful
just like that and [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] women too welcome to Google
roads or at work [ __ ] off okay he's a
guy he at some point he has to get off
the wall and try and make something
happen okay it'd be one thing if women
hit on guys and we could sit there and
be like don't talk about my pecs like
that God stop complimenting me I'm not
saying to be a creep all right
but you got to let her know that you
like her so that's what I would do I
would just compliment her make her laugh
be just be in a good just be a funny
chill [ __ ] person all right don't be
overly aggressive don't be [ __ ] needy
all of that [ __ ] freaks him the [ __ ] out
just freaks him out they run in the
other [ __ ] direction so I don't know I
don't know if you got a sense of humor
or whatever it seems like you do the way
you wrote this [ __ ] and a lot of people
that are needy and and and doubt their
cells are funny people okay so you
complement her be a little
self-deprecating about yourself then she
goes now I think you look good blob a
bun that she takes a step in your
direction and then just [ __ ] go from
there now just one day just look at say
hey listen I know you're only gonna be
here for like a month but I really like
you I think you're beautiful and I'd
love to go out with you let's go hang
out let's go do something I'm [ __ ]
out see that pile of [ __ ] over there
I'll turn it into a bicycle put you on
the handlebars I'll Drive you around go
see a movie or some [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] what she says I'll tell you what
you if she says no that is going to
way less than for the rest of your
[ __ ] life sitting there going you
know when in [ __ ] didn't I ever try to
[ __ ] ask that Colombian check out bet
that lasts a lifetime a woman shooting
you down thank you all you got to do get
how long that lasts that lasts as long
as however long it takes to call one of
your friends to tell him the funny story
back when I started off as a comedian I
swear to God I was bombing so much that
it got to the point while I was bombing
I was already thinking about calling
Patrice and telling him the story and
listening to him laugh at me because it
used to always make me feel better
or Dana Bobby or any of those other guys
that I started out with and like all the
humiliation it was almost like oh good
I'm bombing I have a funny story to tell
those other guys and it stopped being
like a negative thing today go I don't
wanna [ __ ] oversell you on this [ __ ]
but uh good for you
you're young you're in a beautiful
country and a beautiful woman's gonna be
there for a month
[ __ ] uh you're supposed to have fun
all right so there you go
good luck to you sir all right Thelma
and Louise all right I mentioned last
last podcast that me and Nia sat down
and watched that movie and how how
incredible a movie that is how poignant
it is now you could almost look at a
Thelma Louise like it was warning all of
these people now they've got these
YouTube [ __ ] cases that they had
[ __ ] had enough and that they're sick
because everything ever literally every
like strain of different type of creepy
guy or lying or whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call it and held up really well
and then I was talking about that
Kristen MacDonald who plays Daryl what
what that guy just blew me away
all right he said Bill regarding your
mention of Thelma Louise on the March
12th Monday morning podcast a couple of
things I learned about that movie from
the book off the cliff how the making of
Thelma and Louise drove Hollywood to the
edge by Becky
Eggman drove it to the edge I don't know
about that
the movie was almost made with Jodie
Foster and Michelle
Pfeiffer in the lead roles is that
amazing after they cast it and then you
try to picture new people in there like
that one that worked you know both of
them incredible actresses you like that
oh what a [ __ ] would you put them in
there Kristen McDonald who played
Thelma's husband Daryl has been engaged
to Geena Davis at one time a few years
before the movie oh wow he also nearly
stole the movie by improvising a lot of
his role much to the amusement of
director Ridley Scott yeah I thought he
was if you watch Harvey Keitel he's
literally just laughing when watching
the what this guys doing three the role
of hunky cowboy originally went to
Stephen Baldwin I didn't know that who
backed out at the last second to be in
backdraft that's understandable
I probably got a bigger role five actors
were brought back to audition with Geena
Davis for brunettes and an unknown
blonde named Brad Pitt Davis Love Pitt
and he ended up getting the job years
later Davis found herself on a plane
seated next to George Clooney Clooney
made a comment about Pitt stealing a
role from him when they were both
getting started in the business turns
out it was the Thelma and Louise part no
way I love this [ __ ] we should do more
of this on the podcast
George was one of the four brunettes and
Davis had never known it Wow what the
[ __ ] airline is that legit
it's definitely not Southwest group B
can tell you that right now all right
also just saw the Ricky Gervais snip
flicks special humanity in it he has a
nice bit after the 40-minute mark about
intolerance especially related to comedy
there's another segment right after the
one hour mark where he discusses rape
jokes and people's reaction to them
would have crossed the border to see you
in Kitchener tonight but after all it is
st. Patrick's Day and there are bar
crawls and drinking etiquettes to be
observed Aaron go bra you
ellaby know you albino [ __ ]
leprechaun I [ __ ] that up that's Karen
go bra you a lab you albino leprechaun
um anyways oh you know something I
actually learned a lot about Kitchener
cuz I was ask him I go what did you guys
used to make here they just had that
vibe and they all left and I guess they
that was the place where they used to
make Crown Royal the Seagrams family was
from there and Joe bartnick who should
be on their Wall of Fame has said he
said he's thrown out at least 400 of
those purple bags in his lifetime they
also make the best Stryper Stryper the
best sniper rifles in the world where
you can basically be deadly accurate
from two and a half miles away and I was
joking about that like the power of that
like how relaxed you could be you don't
I mean you're two and a half miles away
from the murder scene you know your cell
phones there so you're just gonna be
like yeah I wasn't there
check out my cell phone you know all you
do is put a silencer on the end of the
[ __ ] thing and you just start talking
to one of your friends and then you just
look in two and a half miles down the
road this mother [ __ ] is that son of a
[ __ ] right you got the gun half
disassembled by the time it [ __ ] hits
the gut and you go perfect [ __ ]
murder you know it's funny all these gun
that's it gonna write in actually they
be able to trace the bullet they would
you know ever do the serial numbers when
was gunshot up
joking it's a [ __ ] joke anyways you
know was great about st. Patrick's Day
was I wasn't even aware that was st.
Patrick's Day when I did the Kitchener
gig and we drove all the way back and
then we party at this place called the
Bill Hicks bar
and you go into the bathroom they had
all these quotes of you know Bill Hicks
on the wall those it was a bunch of
stand-up comics hanging out there and we
had a great time because we reached out
and we trying to find a place where we
could actually hang out and drink some
non-alcoholic beers and we want to thank
everybody there at the sober Bill Hicks
bar for letting us act like gentlemen
all right bill I'm a 20 year old
and I lost my older girlfriend who has
kids congratulations this this is a
[ __ ] this is a problem hey Bill I've
been a fan for awhile and I know you
have plenty of advice in that shiny head
of yours not saying any of its good or
professional for the last four months
I've really been beating myself up
because I didn't I didn't stand up for
myself and I let the most amazing girl
I've ever met go back to her ex because
I didn't think I could support her and
her two kids I've had many girlfriends
before dude you 20 before her and I've
been sad about a breakup but not like
this I was drinking heavily and taking
pain pills dude don't do that because I
know I can't have her back I don't know
how to move forward from here I've got
myself off the pills great and I've cut
down the drinking but I can't seem to
feel anything for any other girl I just
don't really have any Drive without her
what should I do now thanks even if you
don't get around to this first of all
forgive yourself all right there's not a
person out there all right that hasn't
[ __ ] [ __ ] up a relationship unless
you just marry the first person that
you're with you know like they used to
do back in the turn of last century
hey I do you know me I [ __ ] up like
three before I found Mia just just
really [ __ ] them up and thought I'd
never get past I mean you know like you
do this is a great time for you okay
because you're what you're learning to
do is pick yourself up off the mat do
you remember well you ever see that
George Foreman fight when he fights
Ollie and he goes down and decades later
they asked him about being down on the
canvas and he said you know what you
know what the truth is he goes I could
have got up I just never been there
before all right
and after that look at him the guy came
back when he was like in his 40s and won
the [ __ ] heavyweight title so look
this is the first time you've been
knocked on your ass like this and this
is great you're gonna learn something
from it
and you're single and you know what the
fact that you can't feel anything about
anybody else know is because you're a
good person you actually have feeling
for this other person so what you do is
you just [ __ ] go out hang with your
friends have a good time if you meet
some chick ask you she asks you what
your deal is say I just went through a
bad breakup
bla bla bla bla bla I swear to god
they'll don't want to cheer you up so
much you'll probably get a [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of it I'm telling you they
love a [ __ ] fixer-upper they love a
little sad goddamn face just say it
[ __ ] up a relationship and I'm
heartbroken about it what's going on
with you as opposed to [ __ ] you know
leading them on and acting like you like
them and then they find out you hung up
on some other girl that's when they get
mad and [ __ ] do the destruction of
property not get prosecuted for it you
know there's actually a commercial out
right now with this woman's just
breaking this guy [ __ ] throwing it out
the window like that's totally [ __ ]
fine
you know I don't understand that at all
so that's what I would say okay buddy I
gotta be honest with you okay I know
she's great and everything but she's
older than you and she has kids that's a
hell of a [ __ ] thing to paratroop
into alright just someday you're gonna
meet another one you're gonna find the
real [ __ ] thing alright and you know
there's not gonna be ill can you support
me and all my [ __ ] kids that I had
with somebody else or I'm gonna go back
to that guy that sounds like a [ __ ]
country song here dude you don't need
that [ __ ] you're gonna find some [ __ ]
girl you know who knows a year from now
two years two now three four years
whatever you're gonna find the [ __ ]
love of your life okay and you know what
you're gonna wish you did someday during
the time before you matter is [ __ ]
went out and had a good time and banged
everything you possibly [ __ ] could
but then [ __ ] reason consensually
with a condom there did I say it right
go out and have a great [ __ ] time
enjoy your [ __ ] life because someday
you're gonna make the girl your dreams
the person you're supposed to be with
all right and you're gonna get married
and you're gonna have a kid and then
even though you'll love all them and
everything you know your podcast is
going to be late cuz you got to go and
you got to go down to the Easter Bunny
you got to do what you can't miss that
[ __ ] and all your free times gonna be
gone it's not gonna be a bad thing
because you're gonna love the kids so
much however you are gonna think back to
a lot of the free time yet think of
Jesus Christ why the [ __ ] did I do this
and that so all this woman did was give
you a great opportunity to go out and
[ __ ] enjoy yourself all right
and when nobody's looking put your face
in the pillow and [ __ ] cry it out of
you do it every day that's what they do
you gotta you got to cry yourself they
never tell guys to do that right cry
yourself into acceptance forgive
yourself and all of that [ __ ] and in the
meantime have a great [ __ ] time
all right go get a kegerator watch a
little March Madness go to the gym get a
great shape there's all kinds of
positive things you can do
all right wife cheated on me night
before our wedding oh boy oh boy the
next one is [ __ ] my roommates sister
Jesus Christ the [ __ ] animals that
listen to this podcast it's almost like
I attract them with my own ignorance
all right wife cheated on me night
before our wedding dear Billy hot lips
my wife and I have been happily married
for 13 years we live in Tulsa Oklahoma
well not to get selfish here with your
extremely painful story but I'm gonna be
and I'm gonna be the Brady theater and
Tulsa Oklahoma come in the next few
months okay all right well we met at the
University of um naka State University
Kate we have two children ages 10 and 7
and have a really comfortable life
together the other night it took my wife
out for a date night dinner and bowling
the bowling sounds lame but remember
it's also do bowling is this [ __ ] you
get in a league it's [ __ ] awesome
anyways my wife and I went up to the bar
at the bowling alley and when the
bartender saw her he gave her a weird
look sort of like haven't I met you
before
after taking our order he came back with
drinks and said enjoy mitzi I was
shocked when he knew her name and I gave
my wife a puzzled look we took the
drinks and went back to our Lane and I
asked her how he could know her name she
said she has no idea and checked her
shirt as if for some reason she was
wearing a name too
after a few minutes when she couldn't
think of an excuse or a lie she dropped
a bomb on me she told me that he was the
bartender from the hotel where we had
our wedding reception
she said the night before our wedding
after our rehearsal dinner her and her
bridesmaids went to the hotel to sleep
and stopped at the lobby bar for a
couple of drinks everyone then went up
to bed but my wife had good friends but
they won't over to Belma but my wife
snuck down to go talk to the bartender
oh wait a minute
my apologies to her friends she told him
that she's getting married tomorrow but
once one more night with another man
before giving herself to me so she took
him up to the honeymoon suite and had
sex with them which by the way is the
same bed that we consummated our
marriage God she told me she was never
going to tell me because it meant
nothing more than her wanting to end her
single life with a bang not a whimper
literally a bang she claims she has
never had doubts about us and that she
is sorry that I found out but she
doesn't regret the cheating because it
assured her that she had found the guy
who she wants to be with forever yeah
buddy you try the same thing and then
tell her that hey it meant nothing and
when I was banging her I was like you
know I yeah yeah I am with the right
broad after hearing this I asked if she
get sheeted since we've been married and
she said no which I believe we left the
bowling alley and drove home in bitter
silence
I'm not spoken to her in about a week
now other than when it pertains to the
kids and other important matters she's
been sleeping in the guest room because
she knows I don't want to be around her
however I know I need to confront her
about this but I am unsure how to go
about it I think the only scenarios are
divorced or basically accepting and
forgiving neither of which I want to do
at this moment what she's you're [ __ ]
right I'm not telling any of my family
or friends about this because I'm
embarrassed so I'm hoping you can give
advice love the podcast and go [ __ ]
yourself I tell her exactly what you
just told me just say that the only two
possible scenarios here are divorce or
me
something and forgiving but I'm not
ready to do either one at this moment
okay and you're gonna have to accept
that and my mood around you because of
your actions all right and by the way
I'm not telling any of my family and
friends about this because I'm so
embarrassed okay and then I would
recommend going to some sort of couples
therapy because that is a mindfuck
beyond any of my barroom [ __ ] advice
but you seem pretty well emotionally
well you know exactly what you're
feeling and why you're feeling it I
would just communicate it to her and she
better not pull this [ __ ] of like see
he's just not gonna talk to me for him
make it about herself I don't know I
think the only way how do you stay I
mean you got to stay cuz the kids are
there which is such a [ __ ] situation
and then all right the positive side is
she actually [ __ ] owned up to it
negative she waited 13 years and two
kids all right let's not do the positive
and negative because I feel like once
this is gonna be like a [ __ ] bad
Super Bowl here yeah I don't know what
is the solution you get to [ __ ] somebody
I don't know and it sounds to me like
you didn't even want to do that so
that's not gonna be a [ __ ] solution I
don't know I would get professional help
when you're ready to sit down and talk
about it
[Music]
listen it'd be one thing if you were
[ __ ] early on in your goddamn
relationship but you were getting
married the next day and then [ __ ] in
the own gut you don't that in in
literally that bed I have to be honest
with you man that's pretty hardcore
that's like guy level piece of [ __ ]
behavior although women are totally
capable of it that's just that that's
not their mo because they're so good at
being pieces of [ __ ] that everybody
thinks they're not
we're guys we just constantly get caught
with the [ __ ] pants down you said
you're gonna be home later
that's your [ __ ] excuse well I mean
aren't you also being dishonest
all right [ __ ] my roommates sister oh
boy alright dear Billy verticals [ __ ] my
roommates sister and I now need your
help
my roommates it's the only way I can get
through these because these are so
[ __ ] said my roommates sister was in
town this weekend while he was out of
town she was going to the bars and some
friends and crashing on her brother's
bed in my place or what-have-you
she invited me out with her and I said
[ __ ] yeah I'm paraphrasing College you
know she is pretty much our same age
mid-20s as I hung out a lot of art with
you know and honey hands hung out a lot
with our group of friends and I've known
her for five years now and consider a
friend outside of just my friend's
sister this is how I justify what the
[ __ ] I did at the end of this letter so
I figured what the hell
maybe she could be a good wingman I
could hit it off with what with one of
her friends unfortunately that wasn't
what happened ain't near just walked in
Nia this guy just found out anyway he
was at a bowling alley he's in a bowling
league with his wife or whatever they're
out bowling because these are so sad I
just have to do it in silly accent
because I want to hear was that a bad
accent that's a funny accent might be
like legitimize jesus-fucking-christ
[Music]
criticism
it never ends what so that's your idea
of a yeah yeah I'm giving you [ __ ] okay
I just seem like a podcast why are you
being so sensitive because it sound like
you were serious Oh see now you're on
Instagram you're gonna get all like
weird about
man I don't know what that I tell you
right now I can't even I don't
understand Instagram what we're at all
the [ __ ] what we're all the Instagram
[ __ ] all I get is just [ __ ] from a
people that I know do you want to be
following Instagram models I want to see
them
well I'm sure after this people will
send you loads of land well you can't
have two ones you look at what are you
giving these shoes well shoes we'll let
those tits hang it up oh so this guy
he's out bowling is taenia is your
[ __ ] ice coffee big enough for you
it's a smoothie I love you all you guys
who drink smoothies to lose weight it's
like a giant chocolate shake I'm not
this is not obviously to lose what I
just want one in a nice natural [ __ ]
Drive do we need to start again I guess
so this [ __ ] guy goes out to bottle
bowling I've been married 13 years he's
got two kids like a ten-year-old and a
[ __ ] seven or eight you know there's
something like that right so they're
bowling and they go up to get some
drinks
and said when they went up there that
the bartender kind of gave his wife a
weird look and then when he gave the
drinks to her he said hey have a good
night Mitzi like new her name so they go
back over and he goes how the [ __ ] did
he know your name and she acted
dumbfounded to the point of actually
pretending to look for a name on his
shirt I don't know and then she just
couldn't come up with a good line she
finally just said the night before their
wedding she banged the guy but hasn't
banged anyone since she goes she said
her and her friends were downstairs in
the hotel lobby drinking they all went
to bed and the night she snuck down and
told the bartender she wanted one last
bang literally before she got married
and went up to the honeymoon suite where
they consummated their marriage the next
night and [ __ ] that guy in that bed
mid-sea you are a dirty dog and then
claim that she never did anything like
that again
and that's pretty reptilian cold-blooded
behavior yeah what's the [ __ ]
bartender doing he's an [ __ ]
there you go Mitzi and you know and you
know he saw the wedding rings he must
like he can't be cool like he just had
to be like my guy well so what is he
asking what do I do
yeah because she's not sleeping in the
thing and he said the only solution is
divorce or I forgive her in the bedroom
what she's sleeping on the cot I know he
hasn't talked to her in a week other
than dealing with [ __ ] that they have to
talk about which is the kids because
he's not ready to and he's saying that
the either they get [ __ ] divorce or
he forgives her but he hasn't told on
his friends and family because he's so
embarrassed I understand that yeah I
mean you made this whole life were there
you have kids with him I don't know is
that really a deal breaker that's the
thing though is she still like messing
around that's the thing the trust is
broken so how do you repair the Tres
couples therapy yeah that's the only way
I mean is she interested in like me she
was she apologizing profusely was she
like I'm so ashamed like I should never
have done it it was wrong you know I
love you so much like I love our family
like I'll do anything to like make this
better because that's that's a hell of a
thing to do to do the night before your
marriage you're getting married in the
bed that you then [ __ ] your husband and
you believe that she's never done it
again I don't know I don't I believe it
because I feel like women can do that
like do that do you see what I'm saying
how good they are at being pieces of
[ __ ] they all cover each other I think
that women can do that guys can't do
that but we can do that you all right
get out I'm kicking you out
can't do that but yeah I feel like she's
capable of life why would you say that
women can do that because I'm talking
about women so why would you say that
BOPE I feel like some people can do that
because I don't have to use your
language to get like my point across but
you just sort of Lee made it just about
women though I just interesting I'm
cross-examining you right now it's kind
of fine as you try to worm your way out
of this [ __ ] it's trying to worm
their way out of anything wriggle yeah
keep drinking you [ __ ] drink they're
so my roommate sister was in town this
weekend while he was out of town she was
going to the bars with some of my
friends and crashing on her brother's
bed in place she invited me out with her
and I said sure I figured she'd make a
heck of a wingman and I could hit it off
with one of her friends unfortunately
that wasn't what happened anyways we
came back to my apartment where she was
going to stay in her brother's bed
before I knew it one thing led to
another and I was banging our Lavanya
wood I wasn't that close fly off and she
bends over it started with some making
out and she was the one who said let's
go to your bed before you start thinking
this is going to turn into the wrong
side of a me-too story hilarious that he
even puts that in there I had sounded
all cash tag me too
all right in the morning we both
regretted it and she said it would
probably be best not to tell my roommate
and her brother about the incident
unfortunately she was able to leave and
go back to her place five hours away
well I have to see the guy every single
day uh okay I also did it with no condom
like a drunken idiot so I've been
freaking out about STDs in pregnancy
even though I'm 99% sure I didn't finish
and made her get plan B the next night
I'm pretty sure he's probably an
accountant major I'm pretty sure she'll
never tell him but I'm kind of a [ __ ]
and feel like I I'll be plagued with
guilt every time I hang out with the guy
what should I do
I'm sort of panicking and have a weight
on my chest for the last week should I
suck it up and go to the grave with this
I told a guy a couple of friends about
this to get it up my conscious and now
I'm afraid one of them might let it slow
dude you don't do that let it slip one
of these nights while we're all out
drinking should I
ahead of the story and just tell them
and suffer the consequences or maybe I
should stop being a [ __ ] and worry about
people with actual problems I don't know
glad you're okay well I I would say this
I would say this you're like that guy
that commits a [ __ ] crime with
somebody else and then you're the guy
they have to whack because you're gonna
flip and what you basically did was you
flipped on yourself and you ratted
yourself out to two other [ __ ] people
alright so in the swirl of trash that's
now gonna happen I bet for upwards of
ten years or maybe never if you do
something like that and you both agree
to keep your [ __ ] mouth shut
that's what you should have done because
this isn't just about you it's also
about his relationship with his sister
alright so you're both adults it was
consensual you didn't want it to happen
it happened then you both said that was
a [ __ ] mistake
nobody's married here there's no kid
involved I wouldn't have said [ __ ] yeah
I think you should just keep a trap shut
and just move on with your life yeah and
you also have to go kill you to friends
you never watch those JFK conspiracies
guys cuz he just felt so guilty about it
yes a telltale heart except this is
ballbag dick throbbing underneath if she
did turn out to be pregnant and capped
it yes of course you'd have to come
clean but you even say go through with
an abortion with that he doesn't need to
know no I wasn't gonna say that what are
you talking about as you said if she got
pregnant she got pregnant and decided to
keep it then you say something but if
she got pregnant and didn't want to keep
it you don't say [ __ ] no but she took
the plan B so is this like this feels
like Fast Times at Ridgemont High I'm
just picturing Judge Reinhold that big
blue car I know but she didn't get an
abortion she took a plan B so it's it's
it's sir do you sell stereos
that's what old people would get that
joke she bang that guy sold the stuff oh
yeah
[Laughter]
how many bangs are right on that [ __ ]
bench yeah
she's such a cutie pie that when she was
that age Jennifer Jason Leigh I like
that moving ageism - she's not a cutie
pie now no she's a beautiful woman now
but she was a cutie pie when she was
younger
mmm-hmm when we return there's nothing
there nothing well that's well that's
the age we live in if there is nothing
here if there's something there or
there's nothing there you're still gonna
be punished oh you look extra pretty
today what'd you do since I left I don't
know you [ __ ] a guy to bone out like
a deer and Mitzi you know what Nia I'm
so old that guy be doing me a favor
baby doesn't have it in him anymore
I'm too old the truth hurts the truth
hurts I tell you I'd rather take a nap
at this point you'd rather take a nap
bang yeah yeah see how that works
everybody that's exactly how it's done
all right that's it that's the best
lesson I could have taught anybody all
right I have a great [ __ ] week you
[ __ ] I'll talk to you on Thursday